disrobing in front of the camera no
longer carries quite the same stigma it
used to but that doesn't mean every
actor is willing to do it
here are some stars who wants willing to
appear naked on screen and the reasons
why Mila Kunis landed the role of Jackie
on that 70s show when she was only 14
years old she's had steady roles ever
since including 2010's Black Swan which
landed her a Golden Globe nomination for
Best Supporting Actress Kunis played a
ballerina in that film and she's
revealed that a physical appearance in
it brought about a good deal of media
scrutiny when she starred in friends
with benefits the following year her
body once again became a subject of
interest Kunis had to do a love scene
with a co-star Justin Timberlake
Timberlake is a friend of hers so as she
told her law the scene wound up being
more funny and mechanical than
titillating I keep my socks on intimacy
issues wait his feet gross me out daddy
issues
great but the issue of nudity still
happened to come up she did show some
side boob but not how we are end as she
puts it you get one or the other you
don't need both in 2007 Mandy Moore was
coming off a string of acting roles that
really cemented her status as a leading
lady in Hollywood between 2006 and 2007
alone she had ten credits to her name
birth according to an interview with USA
Today at the time that number could have
been higher if only she had agreed to
appear nude as she explained they would
be completely uncomfortable to walk down
the street and know that the person
passing by had see me without my clothes
on I've turned down several roles where
their producers or directors or writers
wouldn't budge on that point that no
nudity clause also extends to men's
magazines what more doesn't consider
herself a prude taking off her clothing
is just something she's never wanted to
do as she told USA Today I'm not saying
that it's wrong for someone else to do
them but I think there's a way to be
feminine and sexy without posing
half-naked when Ricky Gervais and
Jennifer Garner were doing press for
their 2009 film the invention of flying
an mtv news reporter made the mistake of
comparing two vases shirtless body to
that of one of Garner's previous
co-stars Matthew McConaughey two-face
took the comment in stride
but it did raise the question as to
whether or not to be willing to take it
all off for a future role Gervase
declared that there was no chance of him
doing nudity when garnet chimed in to
say that
you wouldn't bear all either he
continued okay well then it's equal it's
trying to equal it no way absolutely no
way when pushed however j'avais stood
quietly hint at the prospect of faking a
future nude scene so longer see quote
had a stunt one Sarah Jessica Parker has
a career spanning four decades and over
that time
she's famously refused to appear nude
for any one of her projects in 2018
she spoke with People magazine about her
early experiences as an actress for
calling that there was so much pressure
for her to take her clothes off she was
lucky enough to have her agent in a
corner when the subject of nudity came
up on set she explained my agent sent a
car and a plane to get to the film set
and he said if anybody makes you do
anything that you're not comfortable
doing you don't given what's happening
now and the stories told from that
particular period I know how lucky I am
that there was someone in this case a
man who stepped in Parker also asserted
that her opinion on appearing nude only
extends as far as herself as she also
said it's not a value thing or like I'm
judging anyone else
I just never dug it when it came time to
start filming the finale to the Fifty
Shades trilogy Fifty Shades freed there
was a lot of talk regarding whether or
not audiences would see all of actor
Jamie Dornan co-star Dakota Johnson
joked in 2016 about starting a campaign
for him to disrobe on an episode of
watch what happens live show us the G
and there are rumors that Dornan had
been offered 1.5 million dollars to bear
it all for the final film he didn't
exactly he wore what's called a modesty
pouch instead and he told Al that those
rumors were just that he joked it was 30
million dollars to show one testicle no
that whole thing with offering more
money to go nude that didn't happen for
Dornan the movie wouldn't have been
improved by it he told Al I just thought
we don't need to be flashing the rest if
it's not essential to the story we're
not making porn as much as people think
we are these days Jessica Alba might be
better known for her natural baby and
beauty company the honest company then
for her acting career which started when
she was just a kid with 1994's Camp
Nowhere since then she's starting
countless films and has often played the
attractive love interest for a number of
those roles her wardrobe has been rather
limited but she's never gone fully nude
on
reason for that has to do with her
family as she told glamour in 2014 I
don't want my grandparents to see my
boobs that's it it would be weird at
Christmas Albert also touched on the
possibility of doing nudity for a
particular role or storyline that could
be bettered by it while also taking a
light-hearted jab at our own filmography
as she puts it I mean really if you look
at the movies I have done getting naked
would never elevate the picture
Christina Hendricks worked as a model
for years during her 20s before she
gained mainstream fame as a
strong-willed Joan Holloway on AMC's Mad
Men in 2007 the character was known for
a form-fitting attire leading to Hendrix
becoming something of a modern bombshell
the actress told a black book in 2012
Jem was very openly saying I have sex
and I don't care if you judge me I'm not
going to apologize for Who I am those
qualities resonated with people and have
given me confidence but for as much sex
appeal as Hendricks uses on TV and the
movies he won't be seeing a completely
nude on screen anytime soon and the
reason why might surprise you
while she's comfortable in the privacy
of her own bedroom she isn't so much
that way outside of it as she explained
to black book I'm a very comfortable
naked person not in front of other
people but at home and in front of my
husband I feel good not wearing clothes
Julia Roberts rose to fame when she
played a sex worker with the heart of
gold in 1990s pretty woman while playing
a literal sex worker might be a call for
nudity if ever there was one Roberts
never once appeared without her clothes
in the film she's also remained firm
throughout her entire career about her
personal no nudity stance
according to her nudity isn't really a
part of acting at least not for her
she told OK Magazine in 2007 I wouldn't
do nudity in a film to act with my
clothes on as a performance to act with
my clothes off as a documentary in 2009
Roberts starred in the thriller
duplicitous whose original script called
for a raunchy sex scene but she insisted
that it be toned down by that point in
her life she was married with kids a
life change that seemed to further
cement opposition and the film's
premiere she said you know it's not
really what I do so if you're going to
ask me to do it you have to expect it to
be toned down you know as a mom of three
I feel like that called boom tick
between 2010 and 2017 Ashley Benson
starred on the teen soap drama Pretty
Little Liars in 2012 she shed her good
girl
by appearing in the controversial indie
Spring Breakers the film features a
group of college girls who spend most of
the running time growing little more
than bikinis but for Benson that's as
far as it was ever going to go in a 2014
interview with cosmopolitan the actress
said that she isn't afraid to walk away
when she's pushed to do something she
doesn't want to as she explained I made
it clear that I have a line everyone
tries to push you and it's easy to get
talked into doing those things I'll just
walk off set if that's the way it's
going to be then you can do it without
me for Benson nudity in a film should
never be done graciously and she also
believes that girls look better in
lingerie or a t-shirt while leaving the
rest up to the imagination samuel
l.jackson has been a working actor in
Hollywood since 1973 he has nearly 200
credits to his name and he has never
once appeared fully nude on camera when
he stopped by the Howard Stern Show in
2016 he was asked about going full monty
he recalled doing two nude scenes but
also noted that he had never gone full
frontal it turns out that the reason for
Jackson's modesty has to do with a
certain lack of self confidence I don't
know if it's yeah right yeah smart
formidable enough to you know Jackson's
unwillingness to do nudity might also
have something to do with wanting to
avoid the negative audience reaction
that actors have of bad all have to deal
with that's what you don't want over the
course of its six season run the HBO
sitcom girls featured plenty of nudity
from its stars but Allison Williams who
played Marty Michaels refused to bare
all even before the series began
shooting in a 2017 interview on popcorn
with Peter Travers Williams said there
was only so much she was willing to give
to her character I wanted to give Marni
almost all of myself but I there are
there were things that felt like they
should be mine Williams refusal to sign
the network's nudity waiver was met with
some surprise she said that her agents
just figured she would get swept up in
the vibe of the show and change her mind
eventually but she never did she also
expressed that she didn't want to burden
her potential future children with
another way to be made fun of because
she stuck to her guns now those future
kids will have to write about classmates
showing up to school with Google images
of their naked mom Megan Fox has never
been shy when it comes to showing her
body on camera in her breakout role in
2007 s transformers she generally wore
as little clothing as possible without
quote appearing nude
that's the way she prefers her she told
the mirror in 2016 that she didn't want
her sons to ever have to see her without
clothes on state saying there were just
certain things boy you should never see
their mothers do
foxes no nudity clause is so firm in
fact that she's admitted to walking away
from roles because of it she revealed
there are some good projects I've read
that a with talented people talented
directors but the things of women are
required to do in the movies are things
I can tell my son's ever know or see Fox
added that she once turned down an HBO
project because of its graphic sex
scenes during the late 90s and early
2000s sarah michelle gellar was he
epitome of female badassery playing the
title role on Buffy the Vampire Slayer
in 1999's called intentions she did a
180 by taking on the role of the
manipulative Kathryn who played men like
it was her actual job while a character
lived and breathed seduction she did it
all without ever actually removing her
clothing it turns out that Gellar won't
even go topless regardless of how big
the paychecks would be in 2005 the New
York Post reported that she had been
offered some high-paying roles but
turned him down because she would have
had to take a top off according to a rep
for the actress saira doesn't do nudity
period it has never been a thing maybe
you could get me some clothing yes I
can't just don't go anywhere check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]